neuromuscular Junction is the
specialized synapse between the nerve
and the muscle
when the stimulus reaches the nerve
terminal it would lead to the
contraction of the muscle here we see a
zoomed in version of the nmj where blue
represents the prison apps and the brown
represent the post synapse in the prison
apps neurotransmitter like acetylcholine
would be released which would lead to a
postsynaptic response acetyl-coa
generates acetylcholine with the help of
the enzyme choline acetyl transferase
and it's loaded into vesicles with the
help of WeChat enzyme or which are
transporter and eventually it leads to a
release these are presynaptic events in
the post synapse acetylcholine binds to
muscarinic or cholinergic acetylcholine
receptor in cholinergic acetylcholine
receptor it leads to ionic influx that
leads to the muscle contraction and
that's the postsynaptic response one can
record the postsynaptic response using
sharp electrodes